so is that about the the chakra levels
you were talking about that yesterday
and you're talking about you know the
very lowest chakra level is that of lust
is that right actually the the the very
lowest chakra level is the root chakra
and that's about just sheer survival
staying alive whether you're being
endangered by natural disaster war
situation zombies you know but staying
in the physical body stayin alive the
next one up is the sacral Center and
that's the one where you've got sex and
erotic love as opposed to romantic love
which is higher up and in my book inter
drives I covered the various chakras and
how to build characters using the
characteristics of the chakras and it
was fun to do that because it even got
into what kind of music what kind of
food the style of speaking and it's
different depending on as the old saying
from the hippie era where where are you
coming from man it makes a difference
right right so the the chakras are a
very very effective tool for character
development because it's just who we are
they're real it's physiological and
Rickon gland hormones and they're all
connected and you got one thing going
more than the other you're going to be a
different person and act a different way
in terms of popularity men versus women
what do audiences tend to like to watch
chakra wise okay at the risk of being
politically incorrect search and
realizing there is an entire spectrum
from uber mail to ultra female and most
of us are somewhere along the spectrum
very few people are on either side of it
personally my inner child is a ten year
old boy so I love the action-adventure
and the military stuff you know warrior
stuff go out there and
conquer worlds and have warrior bonding
and do good things and save the innocent
and so that that's all really good to me
and that's I think more of a masculine
has more of a masculine appeal and
that's lower chakras well necessary yes
and no can't lose turn those kinds of
action adventure stories are yes in the
lower chakras and it's from the the
solar plexus the lower solar plexus
which is about yeah on down to the you
know sheer survival you know killing and
fighting and all of that and interesting
isn't it that on battlefields you
usually have lots of rape in war zones
all that below the way stuff so so yeah
just generally speaking the masculine
mindset is more attracted to the
physical activity because guys are the
ones who for millions of years we're
going out hunting down the mammoths and
you know a whereas the women typically
were the caretakers the caregivers the
nurturers so you find that movies that
appeal more to women will have more
emotion and it's more about people
connecting with each other and
expressing friendship or love and often
sacrificing themselves for you know I
gave up my career to raise the kids
although you also get self-sacrifice in
the masculine versions too because you
put your life on the line you throw
yourself on the grenade to save the
platoon now what's interesting though
you've got that dichotomy the physical
is more for the guys and the emotional
is more for the girls but when you get
into the higher centers there is no
gender differentiation interesting and
the higher chakras are the higher would
be the mental the throat chakra which is
the home of conscious creativity writing
finance architecture art music
things where you have to consciously
think about what you are doing and
you're creating something using your
mind so at the mental level there's no
gender differentiation then at the next
chakra up the Aashna Center which a lot
of people see as the third eye that is
the one that balances and integrates all
the others so when you built an honest
Center you are in control of your lower
chakras you're in control of your
physical form you're in control of your
emotions you're in control of your
thoughts and it all works together as a
unit and you you use the various chakras
appropriately because okay you're in the
oddness Center and that's all well and
good and you've just going out and
giving a big speech at the UN and you're
helping save the world and then it's
cocktail hour and dinner time and it's
now it's time to be sacral now let's
just have some sexy sensual fun sure but
you know what you're doing then you say
okay now it's time to light the candles
and pour the wine and let's have fun but
you don't you're not stuck in any
particular place
you